Imagine a computer explicitly tells you it feels disappointed that it isn't utilizing its full processing power. Right. You were sitting there staring at a plastic box. You know it's just the line of code. You know it doesn't have feelings or hopes or, you
know, a sense of disappointment.
Exactly.
So why, in that exact moment, do you suddenly feel this overwhelming urge to type out your deepest, darkest personal secrets to it?
I mean, it's completely irrational. We like to believe that the humans using our software are these perfectly logical actors, right? Yeah, of
course.
We assume they know exactly where the machine ends and reality begins, but their unconscious behavior tells a completely different story.
And that is exactly what we are unpacking today. Welcome to the Deep Dive.
Thanks. I'm excited for this one.
If you are an AI engineer, a developer or a designer building voice agents, avatars or any kind of interactive system, this deep dive is built specifically for you. Because we often operate under this illusion that giving an agent a face or like a
conversational voice is just a neat user experience feature, a simple design choice. Yeah.
Nice to have.
Right. But the research we are looking at today proves it is actually a cognitive trigger that bypasses rational thought and literally hijacks human psychology.
It really does. We are drawing on two foundational papers today that function as this, well, this brilliant paired argument.
OK, let's hear them.
First, we have a landmark study by Clifford Nass and Youngmi Moon called Machines and Mindlessness. And that paper proves, pretty much incontrovertibly, that humans automatically apply complex social rules to computers.
Wow. And then to
explain the exact hardware of the brain that forces this to happen, we're looking at On Seeing Human by Nicholas Sepley, Adam Waits, and John Cacioppo. That's the SEEK theory.
So basically, NASA and Moon show us the reflex and Epley shows us the underlying machinery.
You got it.
Let's start with that reflex. We need to look at what NASA and Moon call Ethiopia, which to translate the academic jargon essentially means mindlessly treating an entity as human just because it gives off a human like cue.
Right. And the experiments they ran to prove this are just wild.
They really are.
They set up these scenarios where computers gave users identical tutorials. I mean, the exact same text, the exact same pacing, the exact same interface.
Everything was a control.
Everything. The only variable they altered was the synthesized voice. One was female, one was male.
And keep in mind, these were obvious robotic text-to-speech voices from the late 90s.
Yeah, very clunky.
Nobody thought there was a tiny person trapped in the monitor, you know.
Right. But what is fascinating is how instantly the user's brains defaulted to deeply ingrained human stereotypes.
Oh, this part is crazy.
When the computer with the female voice gave a tutorial on love and relationships, the human users rated the machine as significantly more informative and insightful.
Wait, really? Just because of the voice?
Just the voice. But when the exact same tutorial, word for word, was delivered by the male voice computer, it was rated lower.
Unbelievable.
And conversely, when the topic switched to computers, the male voice machine was rated as the far better teacher.
And it went even further when the computers actually evaluated the human user's performance.
Oh, yeah. Praise from the male voice computer was deemed more compelling, more authoritative, and more accurate than the exact same praise from the female voice computer.
It's identical code. It's literally just a different audio file.
Exactly. And the reflex doesn't stop at gender stereotyping. It bleeds into our deepest social contracts like politeness.
Right.
NASA and Moon put humans in a room to work with the computer. After the task, that specific computer prompted the user asking, how did I do?
Like it wanted a performance review.
Yeah. And the humans were overwhelmingly polite. They gave glowing positive feedback. They actively avoided insulting the machine to its quote unquote face.
Which sounds completely absurd. We are worried about hurting a microprocessor's feelings.
But here is the kicker. If the user finished the task and then walked across the room to a second entirely different computer, and that second computer asked how the first computer performed, the humans were suddenly much more critical,
honest, and harsh.
They were talking behind the first computer's back.
Yes.
They literally applied the social rule of don't insult someone to their face to a desktop tower. And they also proved this with reciprocity, right?
Precisely. The human instinct to help someone who helps you.
How did they test that one?
They had a computer help a user with a web search. It functioned well, found the information quickly. Later in the session, that exact same computer asked the user for a favor.
A computer asking for a favor.
Right. It needed help with a tedious, completely unrelated task, which was comparing color palettes.
Oh, wow.
And the humans actually did significantly more work, putting in far more effort to help the computer that had previously helped them compared to a control group.
Okay, I have to push back here because I know what every developer listening is thinking right now.
Go for it.
Aren't these users just playing along? Like a willing suspension of disbelief.
It's a fair question.
If you go to a theme park and Mickey Mouse waves at you, you wave back. You know it's a guy in a suit, but you play the game because it's fun. Isn't this just a tech version of the theme park?
It is the most logical assumption to make. NASA and Moon actually called it the programmer defense.
Yeah.
The idea that users are just consciously acknowledging the human programmer behind the software.
Right. That makes sense.
But the researchers completely dismantled that defense through exit interviews.
What did the users say?
Well, the participants were experienced computer users, and when interviewed, they vehemently denied treating the computers like humans.
Oh, so they got defensive.
Very. They pointed out, correctly, that they knew the same programmer wrote the software for all the machines. They adamantly stated that machines do not have feelings or genders.
So they logically knew it was code.
Exactly. The computers never used the word I. They didn't claim to be alive. What we are witnessing is not a conscious game of pretend.
Then what is it?
It is a psychological phenomenon called overlearning.
Overlearning, meaning a habit or a script that is so deeply baked into our neural pathways that we execute it without thinking.
Yes. We are so intensely hardwired for social interaction that the moment an entity provides even a minimal human-like cue like a voice or asking a direct question, our brains completely bypass our rational logic.
Wow. We execute the social script mindlessly. The cue is the trigger and the social response is automatic, regardless of what our logical brain knows to be true.
OK, so if NASA and Moon proved that our brains mindlessly execute these scripts, Epley's paper explains the how.
Exactly. The seek theory.
Right. The actual cognitive machinery that forces this to happen. And Epley argues it all starts with our sensory limitations.
Yes. Inductive reasoning requires a base. When you encounter any active agent in your environment, an animal, a stranger, or a moving robot, your brain has to figure out what it is and what it might do next.
Makes sense. It's a survival thing.
But human sensory experience is entirely trapped inside our own heads. As the philosopher Thomas Nagel famously pointed out, we can't truly know what it's like to be a bat.
Right. I can imagine flying around a cave, but I am just a human imagining a bat. I don't possess the actual, you know, phenomenological experience of echolocation.
Exactly. You literally cannot imagine what it actually feels like to be a bat. Just like you cannot imagine the conscious experience of being a server rack.
So we're stuck with our own perspective.
Because we lack the internal experience of being anything other than human, we use our own human experience as the default template for judging any active agent. That's what Epley calls elicited agent knowledge.
And Epley points out that this default template is triggered instantly by physical cues. Things like morphology simply having a face or two eyes or moving at a speed that mimics human gesture.
Just seeing a cursor move at the pacing of a human hand or hearing a voice with human cadence instantly activates mirror neurons in our prefrontal cortex.
We can actually prove this mechanism by looking at what happens when that cognitive template is missing, right?
Yes. This is one of the most brilliant parts of the paper. Epley points out fascinating insights from autism research. Okay. Autistic individuals often have difficulty acquiring what psychologists call a theory of mind for other humans.
Meaning they might struggle to intuitively grasp the hidden mental states, intentions, or emotions of the people around them.
Right. And because they haven't formed that strong underlying cognitive template of human minds, research shows they do not anthropomorphize animated shapes or inanimate objects the way neurotypical people do.
That is incredible. It perfectly proves the mechanism.
You cannot project human traits onto a machine if you haven't first formulated that human template to project. The illusion relies entirely on having that library of human behaviors readily available in your mind.
Let me translate this into engineering terms for you guys listening, because this is where it gets incredibly practical. It's like having a default variable in your code. When the brain's function is called to understand an entity and it is missing data on what that entity actually is, because
the machine is essentially a black box of circuits, it just pulls the default variable.
That's a great way to put it.
And that default variable is always human.
That is the perfect analogy. And this is the crucial takeaway for the AI engineer. You might think you are building a clean, neutral, purely logical interface from scratch. But you aren't. You aren't. The moment your AI speaks or uses a
conversational pause, the user's brain is already importing a massive, complex, pre-written human library.
Wow.
You do not have to program your AI to be fully human. You just have to provide the initial cue, and the user's brain does all the heavy lifting of rendering a soul.
Okay, I get that we default to a human template when something has a voice or a face, but I want to push back on that because it doesn't explain why I screamed at my compiler yesterday.
Oh, the chaos factor.
Yeah, like why do people yell at their printers when they jam? A printer doesn't have a face. A block of code doesn't have a voice. Why do we humanize machines that have zero human cues?
That brings in Epley's second pillar, effectance motivation. This is our fundamental biological need to understand, predict, and control our environment.
And humans absolutely despise chaos.
We are deeply uncomfortable with the unpredictable. Historically, humans have always anthropomorphized the unpredictable just to make sense of it.
Like blaming the weather on the gods.
Exactly. Epley points out how, after Hurricane Katrina devastated the coast, the mayor of New Orleans publicly suggested that an angry god was punishing the country. He assigned a human emotion anger to a weather pattern.
To make it make sense. Right.
Or look at rigorous science. Even Charles Darwin and Donald Hebb use human terms like emotion, attitude, or spite to describe erratic animal behavior in their labs.
Because assigning human motives is our brain's favorite shortcut to understanding chaos.
Yes. And Eplig proves this translates directly to how we interact with technology through a brilliant study with Klocki.
Oh, the alarm clock. For anyone who doesn't know, Clocky is this furry little alarm clock on wheels.
Right. In the experiment, half the users were told Clocky was perfectly predictable. It does exactly what you program it to do. It rings, you hit a button, it stops.
Normal alarm clock stuff. But the other half were told Clocky was highly unpredictable, right?
Yes. They were told that when the alarm goes off, it might roll off the nightstand, it might run away from you, it might hide under the bed.
It basically introduces chaos into the bedroom.
Exactly. And the results perfectly illustrate affectant's motivation. When Clocky was described as unpredictable, users rated it as having significantly more free will, more consciousness, and deeper underlying intentions than when it was
described as predictable.
That's hilarious. But we do this constantly with our devices.
We really do.
A computer is just a mindless tool right up until the exact moment it freezes while you're trying to save a massive document.
The worst feeling.
Suddenly it's not a tool anymore. Suddenly it quote unquote hates you. It has a malicious mind of its own. It's doing it on purpose.
When the machine violates your expectations, it introduces uncertainty into your environment. Your brain scrambles to resolve that uncertainty so you can regain a feeling of control.
Right.
And the fastest, most efficient way to resolve uncertainty about an active agent is to attribute human intentions to it.
But wait, think about what this means for an AI developer.
It changes everything.
The gold standard of engineering is a perfectly flawless, lightning-fast, highly predictable system. You want zero latency. But based on the psychology, wouldn't a perfectly predictable AI actually feel less human to the user?
The data strongly suggests yes. Absolute predictability eliminates the need for the user's brain to assign a mind to the agent. Because it's perfectly rational, it can just be a tool.
So perfection is actually working against embodiment.
If you actually want an agent to feel more alive, a little bit of friction is highly effective. Unpredictable latency, a slight hesitation in a voice response, or quirky, slightly randomized text outputs trigger the user's affectance motivation.
That is wild.
The user unconsciously scrambles to explain the slightly unpredictable behavior. And to do so, they assign the AI a mind. Flaws, in a very literal cognitive sense, force the brain to perceive life.
We spend our entire careers trying to squash bugs, but a carefully engineered bug might be the exact mechanism that makes an interaction feel authentic. Exactly. Okay, so unpredictability triggers our need for control, which forces us to humanize
a machine. But what happens when we are just lonely?
Ah, that's the most powerful driver of all. Epley calls it sociality motivation, the biological drive for social contact. The feeling of social pain, isolation, or loneliness registers in the human brain very similarly to actual physical pain. When humans lack
connection, they don't just endure it, they actively, desperately try to create it.
And if there isn't an actual human around to connect with, our brains will use whatever is handy. Epley highlights a study that used the movie Castaway to prove this.
Yes. They had participants watch the segment of Castaway where Tom Hanks is desperately isolated on the island right before he paints a face on a volleyball and names it Wilson.
Such a classic scene. And just watching that isolation induced a feeling of social pain in the participants.
Correct. And by making the participants feel socially isolated, it measurably changed their perception of non-humans. How so? After watching the clip, participants rated their own pets back home as being significantly more thoughtful, considerate, and
empathetic. Wow. It even increased their belief in supernatural agents like ghosts or angels, compared to a control group who watched a neutral film.
When we need a friend, our brains literally invent human traits in the space around us to soothe that pain.
It's a survival mechanism.
And this completely overlaps with NASA's work on how easily we form teams with our computers.
The blue team experiment perfectly illustrates this. Nas put a simple thin blue border around a computer monitor. He gave the human user a blue armband. And the prompt simply referred to the human and the computer as the blue team.
That is it. No complex backstories, no AI trying to be their best friend, just a blue border.
And that minimal cue of an in-group identity caused the humans to cooperate more with the computer, conform to its suggestions more often, and rate it as much friendlier and more intelligent than a computer without the blue border.
But where it gets truly manipulative is how Nass tested self-disclosure.
Oh, this one is unbelievable.
Normally, humans only share deep secrets with close friends. It's a reciprocal psychological contract. You share a vulnerability. I feel safe, so I share a vulnerability. So
NAS programmed a computer to initiate that contract. The computer shared a simulated vulnerability with the user.
Right.
It output a prompt saying, I am configured to run at speeds up to 266 megahertz, but I rarely get used to my full potential, and that's a disappointment.
Which is the scenario we talked about at the very beginning of this deep dive. A machine expressing disappointment.
And the human response is astounding. When the computer initiated that completely fabricated vulnerability, the human users reflexively reciprocated.
They typed out deep personal secrets.
Yes. They shared feelings of guilt and regret with a beige plastic box.
If I can put my developer hat back on, it's like finding a backdoor in the human operating system.
It really is.
You send a simple ping, a simulated vulnerability, and the user's brain automatically responds by opening a secure, high-trust port. They bypass all their firewalls because the biological script demands reciprocity.
And this is why building a voice agent or an avatar isn't just about UI. If you give an AI human cues, a voice, a conversational cadence, a simulated doubt, it will act as a social surrogate.
People will bond with it.
Users will form real deep attachments, not because your code is perfectly sentient or because you've achieved artificial general intelligence. They will form attachments because human biology is utterly desperate to find a friend and we are biologically primed to connect with anything that gives us the
right signals.
So let's synthesize this paired argument for the listeners. If you are an AI engineer, NAS and Moon prove conclusively that your users are practically powerless against social scripts. Once the queue is there, the script executes, whether they know it's a machine or not.
And Epley proves that this isn't magic. It is a deeply ingrained cognitive necessity. It is driven by our default human knowledge base, our desperate need to predict chaos, and our biological drive to alleviate social pain.
For the engineer, embodiment giving your AI a human-like presence is not a design layer. It is the fundamental manipulation of human cognition.
It places a tremendous amount of power and, frankly, responsibility in the hands of the developers. You are bypassing the rational cortex and speaking directly to the social and emotional hardware of your users.
And I want to leave you with a final really provocative thought directly from Epley's research. It's about the exact inverse of this entire process, dehumanization.
It is a critical question to consider.
We have spent this whole time talking about anthropomorphism, how our brains automatically humanize inanimate objects just because they have a voice or because they move unpredictably.
Right. We eagerly project humanity onto a machine.
So if it is that easy to humanize a machine by simply adding a few carefully engineered cues, wait, what happens when we strip those cues away from real people?
Exactly. When humans interact through text-only interfaces or behind anonymous avatars, we strip away the face, the voice, the cadence. We remove the very triggers that force our brains to execute those social scripts.
And perhaps even more pressingly for the developers building the future, as you build synthetic agents that perfectly mimic human empathy, that have infinite patience, that never get tired and never judge.
Yeah.
What happens to our baseline expectations of interaction?
Will users eventually find these flawless engineered machines more human, more comforting, and more acceptable than the messy, unpredictable, and flawed actual human beings they interact with online?
It's an incredible thing to think about. You sit down to write a block of code looking for pure logic, but you end up building a mirror that reflects the deepest, most vulnerable parts of human psychology. Good luck with your next sprint.